[Music]
okay we got to go to Grandma's house oh
hi hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to grandma now you know I
was playing that other game called
contempt and I was over visiting my
grandma well this game is I saw a
pentagram dear journal I can't believe
it's been ten years since grandma passed
away she wasn't like many people she
wasn't like the kind and sweet grandma
people think she was my sister had it
worst when we were kids
grandma tormented her and there was
nothing I could have done grandma was a
strong lady for her age she would beat
my sister every time she step out of
line sometimes when I would come home
from school Lily would be in her room
crying because of Grandma something is
wrong I need to find lily she's all the
family I have Maria oh ah okay ah so the
thing about this game is that they say
that it's nothing but jump scares you
know apparently it's the house it Oh
my grandma's house was built back in the
1800s she cherished that house but from
what my sister had told me back when we
were young or the grandma talked to
spirits or something okay is that you
grandma
with Grandpa or Zhou your mistress man
okay it's a little bit janky in here
frame rates a little low but that's okay
so apparently this game is nothing but
jump scares which is fine cuz I'm brave
and I'm ready for it so bring it on and
you jump scary bass what's at the end of
the hole oh it's a grandfather clock I
don't need to worry about that
ain't no thing I know thing I know I
didn't read that what did that say it
went away do I have a journal no okay so
if you guys manage deposit in the split
sir I Oh God
puke and roaches in the fridge loverly
that is okay come on bring it on game
feel like I'm playing slender man's
shadow way back in the day you Shh can i
stuff that grandfather clock in my pants
oh okay
I can't run or else I'd go faster that's
weird
[Music]
all right cool you do whatever you wanna
do war death this in the way Oh death is
the way I thought death was in the way
alrighty then
okay alrighty then what else you got for
me game huh
yeah actually gonna be spooky huh you
gonna try to scare me then I do nothing
for me that ain't gonna do nothing oh no
okay I guess I could try the one at the
end of the hall if you're gonna be like
that yeah it's like I'm playing one of
those horror flash games from way back
in the day
they were good don't get me wrong oh we
see you though sees me huh who sees me
who the hell do you think you are seeing
me for all I know I'm naked walking
around these halls and how dare you
hi hello Jesus you gonna be like that
huh you gonna be like that huh
alrighty then now we're down the way Hey
whoa I saw that at the end of the
hallway I saw that you think I didn't
see that huh
Oh grandma hi grandma
little little egotistical to put a
picture of yourself at the end of the
hallway grandma was a sleepwalker she
would walk up and down the halls from
window to window
my sister would lock her door every
night because of it yeah probably good
idea
wait a minute you said this was built in
the eighteen hundreds then it's got its
got air conditioning no I don't think so
that's something I know about these
[ __ ] houses um I have no idea I don't
know what I think actually I do
nope okay all right all the doors are
locked because of sleepwalking grandma I
don't know what's happening I don't know
what's happening what do I do
squeak oh then I'll just walk again
don't mind me grandma my sister's old
book okay what good is that gonna do me
my sister's old dresser okay great my
sister's old baby
didn't scare me didn't scare me at all
you got a new better if you scare me huh
freakin ass bet oh hi hello thank you
for this where does this go
clickety clack clack key ah so even the
paintings are after me okay that didn't
scare me at all if you want to be able
to scare me you gotta be a lot more
braver than I am and I'm extremely brave
as everybody knows everybody who knows
about me and horror games they know full
well that I'm a brave man hello oh good
great Oh lovely my sister's baby
my sister's painting my sister's baby
crib my sister's other dresser my
sister's bookshelf my sister's window
okay okay oh I didn't even notice the
blood why didn't I notice the blood
blood is something you think I would
notice immediately and not just now all
right oh good blood should I fall oh the
blood
I think I'll follow the blood grandma's
is your blood I don't know if I should
be concerned about that considering
you've been dead for ten years hello is
this go through this hello hi how's he
going my name is markiplier okay I
thought you were gonna slam the door oh
you're not done would you be some piece
of real hard out on that big block down
downstairs
okay you done you done you done now can
I can I go oh okay there we go I got a
key great
cool yeah the key alright skadoosh key
oh oh I can't leave yet
why can't I leave yet why can't I leave
what are you gonna do to me huh it's
like the old school is in the or game
these keep jumpscared means I can handle
it no more well joke's on you my
tolerance for scares is extremely high
what do I do what I do
hello anybody home
anybody hum oh I unlocked the key do I
need to do that to the other one nope
that's locked it's a locked cross okay I
think there's only one more door that I
can open
then you grandma okay good thing the
blood still here worried about that well
come on you don't think I'm brave enough
to be able to handle you you're lying to
yourself oh this is grandma's bed ah hi
what big paintings you have am i what
narcissistic pictures of yours wiser why
is there closet to Narnia so spooky
alright fine I'll go into the closet a
nightmares oh never mind I guess I won't
I thought that was a closet to Narnia
but there's still a shelf in there oh
good a note from Grandma MA
dear journal one night when I was 12 I
heard my grandma yell out stay away I
command you
I didn't know what she was talking about
but now it's almost coming clear to me
she must be a witch oh yeah must be a
witch it seems logical to me I don't
know what else to talk about that seems
pretty cut-and-dry about those
okay grandma's bed is a witch okay I
guess okay
all right then can I go now can I go now
I guess not well that was fun
why did that happen and what are we
gonna do about that hello hello okay
I'll take it I'm not gonna question it
too much but I'll take it
can I go out now can I go home ah is
that so
oh oh oh
new door a wittle a which door okay so
how big is grandma's house cuz that's
what I'm curious about right now I don't
understand
did I do that did I do I don't know if I
did that Rama you can stop pranking me
it'll be great grandma please help me
help me oh here we go
we got here light brings me to life but
darkness kills me I don't know what that
means grandma
you could be less cryptic about things I
gotta get light on killing people and I
gotta get darkness to make people dead I
don't know I don't know I don't know
what you want oh good another door open
just what I wanted coz I wanted to go
into another horrible haunted hallway in
this frickin house alright fine I'll
play your game you rogue you rogue
grandma dear journal when I go to bed at
night sometimes grandma would walk
around in the halls she would come up to
my door and I could hear her breathing
heavily called out door one time but she
didn't say anything she just bought
that's my journal that's my journal
grandma okay alright grandma you're in
hell I get it it's very clever very cool
very good grandma very good but uh could
you stay there that'd be great if you
get to stay there in hell away from us
you wish you happy breathing which that
dies in the darkness oh here we go
ah grandma told me lighting candles can
protect you from harm in any way shape
or form I'm sorry anything maybe
grandma's trying to protect us from the
truth doors can be open not only by a
keep above finding a way around it okay
clickety clackety clickety what did I do
huh huh what did that do huh I lit the
candles was that what I was supposed to
do words that summon demon oh is that a
key that's the key isn't it ghosts ease
over the fear sneeze oh god I'm not
sneezing ah geez who's a horrible
possession about to do would take me
hello hello ah the planchette isn't here
I need to look for it oh do I
because the one thing I need to do in
grandma's creepy ass house is play with
a Ouija board I'm stuck in the door
ah-ha there we go
what a haunted door tried to grab me
with its hands grandma grandma oh you
fell that's okay grandma
it's okay you're in good hands coz
you're in hell remember that about you
being in hell only you stay there again
so this Keys got to go to this other
duel I found it I found it I did I found
the planchette
oh wait did I just drop the key then I
have no idea when I picked up and what I
dropped off I'm gonna play with a Ouija
board now and hope for the best
it's good too oh right yeah this is what
I wanted mojo
[Music]
okay alright that was fun let that
happened I'm done now
apparently nope can't leave okay well
did I play with the Ouija board or wound
the answer is yes I don't know what the
question was but the answer is yes oh
good oh good I may have done a big old
goofy goof and I screwed myself find the
kill okay nevermind man I'm gonna go in
here now hello hi there's a candle can I
lied okay don't get to read that it just
goes away instantly oh okay if anybody
could pause that and try to read that
that'd be great okay grandma that was
unnecessary if you could not do that
ever again that'd be great I have no
idea where I am right now but okay I
can't leave this room until the ritual
is over okay I can see a little better
now oh grandma I saw that well that was
weird grandma in a rocking chair why was
she over there I don't understand what
any of that is bow okay I guess we're
done now I guess we can move on oh now
it's when we crunch the bones oh okay
yeah sure okay we'll go with that one
alrighty then I don't understand your
game and I know
I understand you Graham I'm getting
pretty sick and tired of these games
grandma grandma if you know what I mean
Graham oh okay oh grandma I am okay with
these games you can play as many sick
disgusting games as you want with me Oh
[Music]
old grandma why why are you leading me
down this hallway grandma being a loop
Oh
oh I can go now oh I can go now oh can i
oh hi hello who are you why are you
there why are you there what are you
doing here can I talk to you
hi okay never mind then I'm gonna go
greeted by Scott bored wine alright then
great okay you never did find out what
happen to your sister but I have a funny
feeling the grandma dragged her down and
yell with her I don't know what could
possibly make me fix such as that no
anyway that was good that harken back to
the olden days of poorly optimized and a
little bit rudimentary but still
jump-scare fun
horror games I mean it's fun that's the
whole point right you go through a
haunted house because you want to be
scared and you want people to go oh yeah
and that's kind of like what this leads
into so anyway thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought of this down in the comments
below and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]